et puis bien sûr il y a de très
nombreuses réactions politiques de tous
les milieux à commencé par celle du
premier ministrebar le Premier ministre
était à Lyon aujourd'hui et juste il a
écourté son voyage pour rentrer tout de
suite à Paris juste avant de quitter
Lyon il a fait la déclaration que nous
écoutons maintenant je voudrais exprimer
mon indignation devant le l'ignoble
attentat de la rue copernque et dire ma
tristesse pour tous ceux qui on ont été
les victimes
je rentre sur le champ à Paris de
manière à pouvoir examiner avec le
ministre de
l'Intérieur les mesures prises d' d'une
part pour rechercher ceux qui sont
coupables de cet attentat d'autre part
pour éviter le renouvellement d'actes
aussi
odieux ce soir nous devons nous dire que
un
pays démocratique qui
la
tolérance qui est fidèle à la liberté ne
peut admettre des actes de ce genre
pasanarchie certainement
pas